bonsoir à toutes et à tous je salue en
particulier Monsieur Pascal Lelarge
notre préfet du Haut-Rhin qui représente
également ce soir monsieur Stéphane
Fratacci le préfet de la région
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
il y a surtout des sénateurs des
sénatrices et des sénateurs ce soir
Catherine troncle Patrice achillinger
Jean-Marie Bocquel et René danésie je
salue également Jean rotner
vice-président du conseil régional maire
de Mulhouse qui représente Philippe
Richert président du conseil régional
qui est à trois ce soir trois faisant
maintenant partie de notre belle région
Frédéric Biry est à ma droite vous
l'avez tous reconnu
donc si vous voulez assister à un
spectacle à Strasbourg la Choucrouterie
c'est qu'il aurait ce qui a dit
et je crois d'ailleurs ce prix comme ça
non je pense on s'est inscrit à deux
pour voir ça de près
on va acheter les
Mesdames et Messieurs les représentants
de l'armée des armées de la Justice de
la défense de la police
des services d'incendie et de secours
Mesdames et Messieurs les conseillers
régionaux Mesdames et Messieurs les
conseillers départementaux mes chers
collègues je salue également les anciens
présidents du conseil général
il y en a au moins deux que j'ai repéré
des anciens conseillers généraux ainsi
c'est pas trop de Nice c'est pas trop
c'est la plus
ancien président
donc ils sont moins à deux mais ça nous
fait plaisir je vois que on vieillit
bien dans lorsqu'on a occupé ces
fonctions
ça me rassure pour la suite des
opérations
mais vous étiez aussi là les belles
années vous aviez moins de pression
nerveuses que nous
oui alors j'ai
provoqué Henri Gucci évidemment qui ne
saura que répondre à cette provocation
messieurs les représentants des
autorités religieuses monsieur
Christophe Marx secrétaire général de la
préfecture du Haut-Rhin monsieur
Jean-Noël Chavanne sous préfet de
Mulhouse était annoncé je l'ai pas vu
d'être arrivé entre-temps madame et
Messieurs les représentants des chambres
consulaires
Mesdames et Messieurs les mers qui sont
nos invités prioritaires ce soir et des
présidents des structures
intercommunales Monsieur le Directeur
Général des Services Philippe Jamet
vient là regardez-le il est devant moi
Mesdames et Messieurs les directeurs de
l'administration départementale
départementale mesdames messieurs ne
compte pas les pages à côté de moi toi
je vous souhaite la bienvenue à l'Hôtel
du département où j'ai le plaisir de
vous accueillir afin de partager un
instant de convivialité à l'occasion du
passage à cette année 2016 le climat
actuel c'est pas la pluie ne permet pas
des agapes généreuses mais il me
paraissait important que nous puissions
nous retrouver au moins une fois par an
pour un moment d'échange et il s'agit
d'une première dans les locaux ici dans
le département
2015 aura été marqué par des événements
dramatiques qui ont fortement secoué nos
consciences les attentats parisiens de
janvier et de novembre au restaurant
longtemps gravés dans nos mémoires comme
des actes humains contre la vie et comme
une atteinte ignoble à ce que nous avons
de plus précieux en tant que citoyen à
savoir nos libertés
permettez-moi à ce moment précis d'avoir
une pensée mue pour Quentin Mourier
originaire de Rouffach dont la jeune vie
a été fauchée par les balles des
terroristes au Bataclan nous
compatissons à la douleur de sa famille
et de ses amis
j'ai tellement confiance sur la capacité
de notre pays à surmonté ces
traumatismes je crois également en son
aptitude à garantir à ses habitants la
protection indispensable à l'extérieur à
l'exercice des droits qui font l'essence
même de notre démocratie ceci en
particulier grâce au dévouement et au
courage de nos forces de sécurité et de
secours à qui je tiens une nouvelle fois
à rendre hommage en tant que
parlementaire et nous sommes plusieurs
ce soir ici lors du prochain congrès de
Versailles qui est programmé au mois de
février
j'ai décidé de voter en faveur des
mesures allant dans ce sens l'heure est
à l'unité nationale devant une menace
sans précédent qui cherche à saper les
fondements de notre civilisation face à
ces événements il nous faut bannir des
débats stériles dont la France a parfois
le secret
en 2016 nous aurons encore à nous
interroger sur les réponses que nous
pourrons apporter aux mots endémiques
dont souffre notre pays le pronostic
vital de notre situation économique
sociale et financière reste en effet
sérieusement engagé il conduit nos
concitoyens à persister dans une dans un
certain manque de confiance
hélas chronique à l'égard des dirigeants
nationaux mais aussi de plus en plus à
l'égard des représentants locaux les
récentes élections régionales en ont
livré une nouvelle illustration des plus
alarmantes dont nous aurions tort de
sous-estimer à la fois les causes et les
conséquences les résultats de ce scrutin
ont été particulièrement révélateurs des
inquiétudes de nos compatriotes face à
un quotidien difficile pour un nombre
sans cesse croissant d'entre eux mais ce
facteur ne suffit pas toujours à
expliquer un vote aussi important en
faveur de l'extrême droite notamment
dans des communes particulièrement
paisibles qui ne comptent quasiment
aucun ressortissant étranger et dont le
taux de chômage est relativement faible
en fait nos concitoyens sont déboussolés
car leur propre identité est mise à mal
identité nationale mais aussi régional
cette dernière étant piétiner depuis
bien longtemps et ayant même subi un
nouveau coup très rude vous le savez à
travers la création des mégas région
notre modèle politique arrive sous de
nombreux aspects à bout de souffle à
défaut de pouvoir régler les difficultés
essentielles que connaît notre société
nos gouvernants nous inventent parfois
de faux problèmes pour mieux éluder les
vraies questions il en va ainsi
notamment du redécoupage des régions et
de la loi neutre aucune de ces réformes
apportent la moindre rationalisation de
la gestion publique ni la moindre
réduction des strates administratives ni
la moindre baisse du nombre d'élus les
coûts de fonctionnement vont encore
inévitablement augmenter sans aucune
plus-value pour les citoyens
les élections régionales ont encore
confirmé les valeurs que nos concitoyens
attendent le plus de ceux qui les
gouvernent ces valeurs dont chaque élu
doit être le porteur à savoir la
sobriété dans la gestion des finances de
sa collectivité la rigueur dans son
action et la vérité dans son discours
2016 pourrait être une année de bonne
surprise pour notre département à
condition d'y mettre du courage de
l'inventivité et de l'enthousiasme du
courage d'abord nous en avons déjà fait
preuve notamment pour dire la vérité sur
la situation financière de notre
département mais aussi pour expliquer
des conséquences sur l'aide accordé à de
nombreux et fidèles partenaires qu'ils
soient privés au public nous avons ainsi
démontré qu'il n'y avait aucun tabou sur
aucun dossier que chacun d'entre eux
pouvaient être abordé chaque dossier
pouvait être abordé en toute
transparence sans le moindre préjugé
mais aussi sans précipitation afin de
faire émerger la solution la plus
appropriée la question de la maison
d'Alsace à Paris et celle de la fusion
des agences économiques et touristiques
sont sans doute des exemples
emblématiques de ce pragmatique qui doit
prévaloir dans le traitement des
affaires départementales les plus
sensibles je sais que mon homologue
barinois Frédéric Berry que je remercie
de sa présence partage pleinement cette
analyse nous la mettons aussi en œuvre
par exemple dans notre volonté de
dépoussiérer la réglementation du
travail dominical qui relève de la
compétence de notre assemblée
nous serons naturellement attentifs
l'oral Bas-Rhin aux préoccupations à la
fois des commerçants du monde économique
mais aussi des salariés et on va essayer
d'avoir des délibérations concordantes
pour éviter des concurrents sur les
zones frontières
entre le roi et le Bas-Rhin le courage
en politique c'est avant tout savoir
décider et ce courage là je l'assume
pleinement du courage justement il nous
en faudra encore pour affronter de
nombreux défis il y a notamment se
lancer par la réforme territoriale à nos
départements des filles de l'explosion
des dépenses sociales le défi de la
baisse draconienne des dotations de
l'État le défi de l'équilibre budgétaire
le défi du transfert de compétences le
défi de l'aménagement et de
l'accompagnement de nos territoires des
défis multiples à destination d'une
collectivité à laquelle on demande de
faire toujours mieux avec toujours moins
nous parviendrons à relever ces défis
parce que nous avons la foi et parce que
nous savons que notre génération devra
apporter sa part au progrès de nos
territoires nous nous sentons soutenus
par nos concitoyens qui nous ont
accordés largement leur confiance en
mars dernier du courage et de la
détermination il nous en faudra
également
prendre à bras le corps un certain
nombre de dossiers pour lesquels nous
attendons de la part de l'état des
prises de position claires et lisibles
il en va ainsi notamment du sort de la
centrale de Fessenheim dont je rappelle
les forces enjeux à la fois économiques
et sociaux la centrale c'est 400
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
ce sont 2000 emplois qui sont
susceptibles d'être affectés par le
projet de fermeture bien entendu que la
fin interviendra un jour mais il faut
que cette fermeture s'accompagne de
mesures de compensation significative et
planifiée dans un horizon suffisamment
long pour permettre la reconversion du
site dans des conditions financières
acceptables il en va ainsi également
d'une mesure indispensable en raison
notamment de ces enjeux de sécurité et
de fluidifier fluidité de la circulation
celle de l'interdiction Monsieur le
Préfet de dépassement imposé aux poids
lourds sur la 35 entre Colmar Mulhouse
éventuellement ça Louis comme nous
l'avons déjà évoqué ensemble du courage
il nous en faudra enfin pour nous
interroger sur la façon optimale de
porter des intérêts alsaciens au sein de
la grande région cette dernière vient de
désigné son premier président en la
personne de l'un des nôtres Philippe
richesse qui est retenu comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure ce soir à 3 et je
sais pouvoir compter sur Jean rotner
vice-président pour lui transmettre nos
chaleureuses félicitations et nous
rendons nous encouragements pour revenir
à la canne ou l'ALCA faudra choisir je
suis convaincu que la vraie réforme des
collectivités locales restent
encouragevée en simplifiant la carte
administrative et en favorisant la
proximité de l'action publique dans le
respect des territoires les
rapprochements en cours entre les deux
départements alsaciens et leurs
collaboration renforcées avec les
agglomérations de Strasbourg de Colmar
et de Mulhouse seront l'une des clés de
voûte de cette réflexion je pense que
générique partage avec moi cette
préoccupation d'autres hypothèses
complémentaires resteront encore
ouvertes je suis en effet persuadé d'une
autre chose les solutions aux
problématiques les plus sensibles aux
yeux de nos compatriotes ne peuvent être
que locales et elles ne viendront plus
d'un État qui aujourd'hui qui est
aujourd'hui financièrement à fixé il
faudra plus que jamais compter sur nos
propres forces locales je disais du
courage mais aussi de l'inventivité
celle dont nous allons devoir faire
preuve pour répondre à notre échelle à
des enjeux mondiaux aussi fondamentaux
que celui du réchauffement climatique ou
encore de la transition énergétique de
l'inventivité également afin de rendre à
notre département la prospérité qu'il
mérite et qui passera inévitablement par
le respect de certaines lignes de
conduite première de cette ligne de
conduite c'est l'élaboration et la mise
en œuvre
une politique sociale la plus équilibrée
possible
entre les droits et les devoirs ceci est
indispensable afin de continuer à
exercer pleinement notre obligation de
solidarité à la fois à l'égard des plus
fragiles et des plus âgés de nos
concitoyens dans un souci surtout aussi
d'équité et de justice sociale les
décisions récemment prises dans le
domaine du RSA et tendant à favoriser le
contrôle exercé sur ses bénéficiaires
ont montré la voie dans ce sens ni
diabolisation
mystigmatisation juste à volonté
d'adapter au mieux nos moyens déclinants
aux besoins grandissant de nos
populations et le besoin aussi d'établir
un juste droit à l'obtention d'un
soutien de notre collectivité deuxième
ligne de conduite le développement de
notre collaboration avec nos voisins
ceci afin de continuer à valoriser nos
atouts communs et à développer nos
complémentarités
dans cet ordre d'idée je souhaite
évidemment que le rapprochement avec
notre collectivité sœur se renforce
encore davantage que nous puissions
solidifier nos points de convergence et
concrétiser nos volontés partagées parmi
elles bien sûr celle de porter haut et
fort la voix de l'Alsace à l'échelle
nationale et transfrontalière j'appelle
aussi de mes deux la poursuite d'une
coopération lisible et visible aux yeux
de tous avec nos partenaires suisses et
allemands une coopération qui sera
encore davantage basée sur des projets
concrets
tels que l'euro Airport par exemple ou
encore la réalisation du technopore à
salouy je salue en particulier les
représentants des institutions
allemandes et suisses présents ce soir
troisième ligne de conduite la
refondation de toutes nos interventions
et la mise en place d'une organisation
interne sachant s'y adapter le Conseil
départemental du Haut-Rhin sera répondre
à la réduction de financiers par une
optimisation de ces moyens humains ceci
seront ainsi davantage orientés vers
l'ingénierie l'expertise et
l'accompagnement des projets locaux
cette évolution se fera sur le pilotage
de notre nouveau directeur général des
services Monsieur Philippe Jamet et elle
se réalisera grâce à l'engagement de
tous nos cadres dans une démarche
résolue de modernisation de
l'administration et à travers la
mobilisation de tous nos collaborateurs
aux compétences affinées autour de
politique au préalable revisité en
profondeur par l'assemblée
départementale
courage inventivité mais aussi
enthousiasme cet enthousiasme j'ai déjà
pu le constater l'apprécier durant ces 9
premiers mois de mandat de la part de
mes collègues conseillés départementaux
et je tiens vraiment à les remercier ce
soir nous formons et véritable
Mannschaft comme on dit pour reprendre
donc ce terme du langage sportif
à savant mélange d'expérience et de
jeunesse de défauts masculins et de
qualité féminine
et vice-versa
de bon sens rural et de réalisme
de diverses sensibilités territoriales
qui s'avèrent sans doute plus
constructive que si elles étaient
dictées par des considérations
politiques voire politiciennes vous
connaissez ma position sur la réforme
territoriale mais il y a un point
positif que je souhaite relever c'est
celui de la parité qui a insufflé dans
notre assemblée je crois que les
fonctionnaires partagent ce sentiment
invent vivifiant de fraîcheur de
nouveautés et surtout de compétences
nous constituons en effet je crois
une équipe riche de ces complémentarités
et fort de sa volonté unanime de faire
avancer le département
ceci devra rester sa marque de fabrique
en 2016
Laura continue par ailleurs à se
distinguer par l'audace de ses
entrepreneurs par l'engagement de ses
associations par la passion de ces
bonnes vols par l'ambition des projets
initiés dans ces territoires et par le
sens des responsabilités de ces élus
locaux le Conseil départemental du
Haut-Rhin sera continué à les
accompagner au mieux de ses possibilités
je m'y engage avec tous mes collègues
alors que nous devons trouver 30
millions d'économies de fonctionnement
en 2016
en 2016 rien que dans le fonctionnement
sachez quand même que nous allons
consacrer cette année 2016 70 millions
d'euros à l'investissement
donc c'est on reste quand même très
présent malgré le message qu'on peut
parfois retenir on reste quand même très
présent dans le domaine de
l'investissement
sur ces 70 millions plus de la moitié 40
seront affectés à l'aide au tiers
donc on investit plus d'argent vers
l'investissement des tiers de communes
des intercommunalités que pour
nous-mêmes
pour quelles raisons parce que nous
tenons autant que possible à respecter
les engagements qui ont été pris
notamment dans les cadres des contrats
de territoire de vie
le Conseil Général était par le passé
une grand-mère argenté
et généreuse
on venait d'avoir le dimanche de temps
en temps
qui permettait à s'engrandes familles
urinoise de la grande famille au
rhinoise de boucler ses projets
après ces réformes successives notamment
budgétaires le Conseil départemental
d'ailleurs qui devait disparaître il y a
deux ans vous en souvenez est redevenu
une jeune fille
qui doit compter tous les mois pour
boucler son budget
mais cette jeune collectivité se trouve
pleine d'enthousiasme pour affronter
l'avenir avec ceux qui l'entourent en
particulier des mers qui sont les
moteurs du développement des territoires
alors que Michel Delpech vient de
disparaître nous avons tous en tête ces
paroles Dieu que Marianne était jolie
quand elle marchait dans les rues de
Paris en chantant à pleine voix ça ira
ça ira toute la vie
du courage de la nantivité et de
l'enthousiasme voilà donc à mon sens ce
que 2016 continuera à exiger de nous et
que nous continuerons à rencontrer chez
vous chers partenaires et amis j'en suis
convaincu il me reste à vous souhaiter à
vous toutes et à vous tous ainsi qu'à
tous ceux qui vous sont chers une
nouvelle année aussi courageuse et
inventive et aussi enthousiaste que
celle que je propose avec mes collègues
et nos 2400 collaborateurs de mettre au
service des eurinois excellente année
2016 à clécliste merci